la parole de notre collègue Valérie
Boyer pour le groupe les républicains
merci Monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre j'ai
associé mon collègue Laurent saumon à ma
question il y a trois mois alors que le
vice-président du Sénat Roger carochi
vous interrogez sur le rapatriement des
femmes et des enfants de djihadistes
vous avez répondu je vous cite en
réalité notre doctrine n'a pas changé
ironie ou mépris en effet depuis 2009
c'était le cas par cas pour les enfants
dans une logique purement humanitaire et
la tolérance zéro pour les femmes et je
ne veux employer le terme rapatriement
car il s'agit de revenant nous apprenons
par la presse que 15 femmes et 32
enfants sont revenus sans compter les 31
femmes et des 67 enfants l'année
dernière
assumez vous ce changement de troctrice
c'est-à-dire l'abandon du cas par cas et
ses retours massifs comment assurez-vous
la prise en charge de ces enfants par
les services de l'aseu déjà au bord de
la fixie comme l'enfermement de ces
femmes dans nos prisons déjà saturés et
qui sont considérés parfois comme des
héroïnes comment pouvez-vous garantir la
sécurité des Français face à ces
personnes qui haïssent toujours la
France
pour vous répondre la parole
est au Garde des sous ministres de la
Justice
sur dupont-mory
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs madame
la sénatrice Boyer ni ironie ni prix
votre champ lexical aurait peut-être pu
vous permettre d'envisager d'autres
choses nous n'avons pas changé la
position du gouvernement est extrêmement
claire et elle est précise ceux qui ont
choisi daesh doivent être jugés au plus
près des lieux où ils ont commis leur
crime mais mais ça n'est pas un petit
mais il y a des enfants madame la
sénatrice oui qui n'ont rien choisi et
qui doivent être traités avec humanité
et vigilance
humanité parce que ce sont des enfants
et j'ajoute des enfants français ne vous
en déplaisent
et vigilance parce que ils sont
susceptiblement
susceptiblement possiblement d'être
traumatisé à vie avec toutes les
séquelles que cela peut-ongendrer alors
non nous n'avons pas changé nous
rapatrions à la demande chaque fois que
cela est possible des femmes qui le
demandent avec des enfants en ayant
naturellement à l'esprit la sécurité de
nos forces de l'ordre qui se trouvent
sur place parce que nous ne maîtrisons
pas tout les femmes ont toutes fait
l'objet d'une judiciarisation quand aux
enfants ils sont placés parfois auprès
de leurs grands-parents qui sont des
gens parfaitement intégrés parfaitement
honnêtes et je le redis parfaitement
français madame la sénatrice voilà les
enfants font l'objet d'un suivi
sanitaire d'un suivi médical d'un suivi
psychologique fermeté pour les femmes
humanité vigilance pour les enfants on
pourrait tomber d'accord là-dessus ça ne
lit de l'ironie ni du mépris
madame Boyer
monsieur le ministre
humanité vous n'en avez pas le monopole
et personne ici ne peut nier que nous
aussi nous souhaitons traiter les
enfants en revanche en revanche la
doctrine du cas par cas avait été
adoptée par vos prétesseurs Monsieur Le
Drian et Madame beloubet qu'en est-il
aujourd'hui pourquoi changer vous de
doctrine en openant désormais pour des
migrations mortifères massives le
président Macron le président Macron
lui-même considérait que ses retours
étaient trop dangereux pour la sécurité
des Français qu'en est-il aujourd'hui
des personnes qui restent combien
sont-elles vous injecter dans la
population française des djihadistes
alors que notre pays est déjà gangrené
par le salafisme n'oublions pas
n'oublions pas que la France avec 1400
individus et le premier pays européen et
le deuxième pays au monde à avoir fourni
des terroristes à l'état islamiste
avec des femmes qui se sont engagées
pour aller combattre en Syrie et en Irak
contre la France aujourd'hui avons-nous
les moyens d'une telle politique